Dustin is on Twitter you can follow me
on Twitter at Dave Ramsey if you want to
get into the trouble whether we get into
some trouble occasionally on Twitter
Dave do you recommend mutual funds over
a comparable ETF
well in ETF Dustin as you may know is an
extract exchange-traded fund and what it
is it turns a mutual fund into a stock
of sorts and enables you to jump in and
out of a mutual fund without are the
equivalent of a mutual fund without fees
the vast majority of ETFs are index are
based on index is like an S&P 500 as an
example so a nolo - S&P 500 versus an ET
ETF that is in a SP 500 there's
virtually no difference in them and so
do I recommend good growth stock mutual
funds that outperform the SP above an
S&P 500 index ETF or fund yes yes I own
many many mutual funds that outperform
the S&P 500 and they're not that hard to
find a lot of funds don't outperform the
S&P 500 and you should not buy those but
ETF is not a guarantee and if you're
going to jump in and out of the stock
market you're not following anything I
teach you now the ETF is good for that
the exchange-traded funds are very good
if you want to jump in and out because
you got no fees and you're trading it
like you're trading your mutual fund
like you're trading the stock then but I
don't recommend timing the market and I
don't recommend jumping in and out of
the market all the data shows us that
that is not good investing that's
speculating and speculating on the S&P
500 is pretty stupid straight up because
now you're really trying to time the
overall market not even a segment of the
market and so really low probability of
you doing that so if you want to buy an
S&P 500 and you want to do it with an
ETF sure it's an efficient way to do it
I'm not mad about it I've got a lot of
money in S&P 500 because they have low
turnover ratios and I don't get taxed on
them until I pull the money out
and when I do pull the money out I get
taxed at long-term capital gains if I've
held it for at least a year so I use it
because there's low turnover ratio but
to use ETFs instead of the four types of
mutual funds that I recommend no I would
never do that because the four types of
mutual funds that I recommend I can find
them that outperform an S&P 500 which
98% of you dealing with ETFs are doing
an S&P 500 spider what you do and that's
okay it's alright it's not bad it's just
not the best my personal for mutual
funds in my 401k have outperformed the
S&P 500 by a point and a half net of
fees after all fees have outperformed
the S&P by o point and a half in the
last ten years it's really not rocket
science to find them so you know no I'm
not a big ETF guy and that's the reason
because I'm not a big index fund guy
because I can find funds that out there
outperform them we recommend you spread
your investments into four categories
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international and in each of
those you will find corresponding
indexes that you can outperform okay
aggressive growth would be the Russell
Index growth would be the sp500 growth
and income would be the S&P 500 and the
international you can find an
international index to compare it to but
you can find those that outperform in
those areas and I'm going to put my four
funds and those in my personal 401k at
beat the S&P 500 after fees so yes I
recommend mutual funds of that type over
ETFs because they're not comparable
because they outperform them this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
you